This season on Direct From
We're in the Palestinian town of Nabi Saleh
We travel to the occupied West Bank
Right across the road over there is the illegal Israeli settlement of Halamish
to meet the teenage girl who's become an icon for Palestinian resistance
and we go to Canada,
where indigenous activists and water
protectors are fighting for their land
These protesters have taken over one of the busiest intersections in Vancouver.
How far are you willing to go stop this pipeline?
–It's in my blood not to stop.
This is unceded traditional territory. You’re not welcome here!
And fighting for their safety.
It flashed through my mind that it could be a body that we were trying to pull up.
They come across remains and you don't know if they're human or not, or if they're your sister.
The march is to send a message to
the men who prey on them that they're
being watched by the community.
They feel like they don't deserve it. But they do.
Put the camera down. Okay, okay!
This is total chaos right now…
Make sure to follow the Direct From playlist on YouTube and subscribe to AJ+.